Very quickly. Now, let's talk about the applications of what we've
talked about.
with respect to discrete mathematics
and then we will switch to vs code to start
our tutorial.
now
again, what you see on the left are the topics that
will be covered in discrete Mathletics. And at the right we have
the applications of these topics.
Set sets are.
the first thing that you will deal with
in programming a data sites or for that matter anything in
mathematics.
But of course being able to read the notation.
Set notation.
is a prerequisite for
being able to read
any text on data structures. So for
example, we have very two well-known books on data structures
algorithms.
One of one of them is from corpsman at all
on introduction. It's called introduction to algorithms. And the other one
is from Robert Sedgwick.
And the book the title of the book is also algorithms.
so you will find a lot of
Set notation in those books. If you want to on be
a master of data structures, they need to be able to read those
books. And if you want to be able to read those books, you have to be
very very familiar with set notation. But of course
this is not just limited to those books. Like I said sets are
ubiquitous in all of mathematics.
probability Theory abstract algebra calculus
linear algebra and
calculus
so
if this is your first time hearing about the screen
mathematics, that's that should be a starting point.
Logic, we talked about logic and how it is
important to running efficient algorithms.
algebra
And once again, I'm referring to an algebraic
structure. This one again is something you
you ubiquitous and higher level mathematics. Well,
for example, if you want to understand computer Graphics,
which uses a lot of you know,
computer graphics and computer vision. They used
these fields use a lot
of advanced mathematics and a
big part of it is of course.
understanding things like vector spaces
and linear algebra is Central to
computer graphics and computer vision.
And if you want to read linear algebra and really understand Concepts
and linear algebra.
The prerequisite is abstract algebra.
and
how do you learn abstract algebra? Well, you need to start learning
sets.
Because once you learn such then you can understand the derivations
of sets.
So things like
field Rings groups
like to say Vector spaces Etc.
cryptography
I mentioned this before at the heart of cryptography is
our prime numbers
and divisibility which is what congruence is about.
compression
So how does compression work compression uses?
tries to use bits
to represent and call it characters.
So if you've heard of utf-8 or utf32.
And let me show you something very quickly.
So this is how encoding Works to encode
means to?
represent
alphanumeric characters or all
types of characters that can be represented on
the computer using
a
specified
number of bits
so for example in utf-8
In a utf-8 encoding scheme
you use eight bits of characters to
represent any type of character.
whereas in
for example 16 utf-16 used
16 bits of characters.
Why does this matter well the more?
bits
you allocate to a character.
the more character variation you
can store
Yes, because the more bits you have available the more characters you
can store.
now
it's nice to have it's nice to be able to be able to
represent all kinds of characters.
the problem is every single character will then
take
that much of space. So for example, if you have a file with utf32
encoding each
character.
That you put in a file. Let's say you have a text file right and you set it
set the encoding to utf32 every single
character that you type into
that file will consume 32 bits
of space.
even a space even a period even
a comma
will take up 32 bits of space. This will
take a lot of
disk space very quickly.
So when possible you want to choose the appropriate encoding
if you're going to be using all the English or that letters you
can use.
something like utf-8
but if you will be right if your file is going to contain other languages
or
let's say mathematical symbols. You will need a different encoding
scheme.
So how does compression work compression will one type
of compression technique is to vary the number of
bits.
so as opposed allocating every single character
the same bit allocation a
compression algorithm will
change the number of bits.
If there's a for example a character that appears frequently
like a space where we can represent the spaces
or the small number of bits and there's a way we can arrange the
bits so that when we decode when we decompress the
file.
We get the same we get the original file.
What is the mathematics that concerns or where's the
mathematics that you would need to understand to?
read and
implement
compression. Well, the prerequis the prerequisite
is relations, which we'll look at in a moment.
functions have very wide uses functions
are
Very fundamental, but if I can give you one of
many instances it would be abstraction.
Functions in programming at least allow you to abstract away.
Sequences of code or sets of instructions which we
call algorithm for later use and then you can
take multiple functions abstract them again.
Into a super function if you like, but that's
not the best word. What I'm referring to is a
class.
classes allow you to
Do object oriented programming so the
larger your application gets the larger your program becomes?
You want to introduce more and more abstractions and functions allow
they do that very effectively.
And then of course counting which I said.
Is another name for combinatorics?
And combinator by the way.
Discrete mathematics. Once again, according to the Princeton
companion to mathematics discrete mathematics
is sometimes known as carbonatorics.
Because this mathematical Branch this discrete mathematics.
Is about using clever.
It's about using.
different techniques
to represent numbers
to reduce complexities
to know the different number of ways in which
mathematical objects can be arranged.
And of course one example, I put here is approximation
how to approximate a very large number of continuous
number using bits,
which is what computers do after all.
So these are all the small.
number of
things that you would be able to understand if you
Are able to read and understand?
the items on the left
if you want to be perfect if you want to be able to work in
these areas.
Then what you see on the left is a prerequisite.
All right.